good morning with john langler and
heather mills at the anchor desk sheri
swens talking about the weather nathan
town and i'm starting off this half hour
with a complete freeway closure this
could be a game changer for your commute
particularly if you're in the centennial
hills area anywhere in alliante if you
use the south 95 to get into town you're
gonna have to find another way around we
have a multiple vehicle crash on the
south 95 at craig road now this map is
incorrect i have an email into the folks
that control this we got to get that
purple off of there because northbound
95 is open as you can see on this live
picture meanwhile this is the southbound
closure of the 95 at craig road nhp says
this is actually a metro police incident
that nhp is just helping out with
traffic control but as we get after 5 30
which is where we are right now this is
going to turn into a big parking lot
back to the centennial bowl so how do
you get around this if you're detoured
off the south 95 at craig you can go
east over to rancho and continue down to
say lake mead that would be the same
thing if you go west over to buffalo or
even durango then continue your south
trip i'm not sure about getting back on
at cheyenne but i believe you can get
back on at lake mead this is going to be
a big game changer for your commute this
morning so change your travel plans the
south 95's closed at craig road